the taliban says is discussed turning a
new page with the united states during
face-to-face talks in doha the acting
foreign minister amir khan mutaki who
leads the taliban delegation says
they've also discussed aid and getting
kobit 19 vaccinations into afghanistan
before the meeting the u.s said it was
going to push the taliban on issues
including evacuation flights and how
it's guaranteeing the rights of women
and girls and minorities security of
course another big talking point
particularly the threat posed by isil in
afghanistan the armed group's latest
attack in a shia mosque on friday killed
more than 60 people we have two
correspondents tracking this story
shortly we'll speak to osama bin javad
about what's been going on in kabul in
the lead up to these talks first to
natasha ghanam here in doha so natasha
what have they been talking about
well i do want to note something that uh
that you just mentioned the acting
foreign minister malvi amir khan moktaki
said which is that these talks in his
view represent the opening of a new page
between kabul
and washington bear in mind these are
once uh enemies on the battlefield now
representatives of governments sitting
around a conference table so this
diplomatic dance begins there's a chasm
between the two sides that now somehow
needs to be diplomatically bridged with
concessions the acting foreign minister
said that the primary focus of the talks
thus far were about the distribution of
much-needed humanitarian aid there is an
evolving and deteriorating humanitarian
crisis in afghanistan and concerned by
the americans that humanitarian aid is
not being distribu distributed smoothly
the acting foreign minister said that
the afghans will ensure
that the aid is distributed however it
did not make mention of the united
states concerns that female
aid workers are not being allowed to do
their jobs unimpeded another topic of uh
conversation according to the foreign
minister was implied implementation of
the doha agreements here you have the
taliban once again though reminding the
world and the united states that its
sovereignty cannot be interfered with
that quote uh we don't want anyone to
interfere in our internal affairs
the taliban leaders came here with for
sure money on their minds they have
asked the united states to lift
sanctions and restrictions on the afghan
national bank in turn the afghan
delegation says that it will work on
paying government employees and
providing services
to the population
in turn apparently the american
delegation has pledged to provide
covid19 vaccinations
for afghans now one of the things that
is surely a point of common ground
between the two groups is this issue of
security uh
afghanistan is reeling from two major
bombings in the last week that have
killed dozens of people and though
publicly the afghans have said that they
will not work with the united states to
help weaken isil in afghanistan clearly
both sides want to provide some
stability and from the americans point
of view stability and money go hand in
hand the foreign minister said that the
that afghanistan is aware that making
the country stable is in the best
interest of the international community
and it plans to do what it can to work
towards that the united states has said
from the onset that this meeting is what
it is is a continuation of pragmatic
quote um
engagement with the taliban and what it
is not from the american perspective is
recognition of the taliban or conferring
legitimacy those are direct quotes so
it'll be interesting to see where things
go from here but as is always the case
these types of things begin with an
initial first meeting and that's what
we've had so far in doha today natasha
thanks very much live now to kabul and
our correspondent there osama bin laden
so osama is it significant that when
they were putting the delegation
together the embryonic taliban
administration i guess they would say
we're going to become the government one
day pretty soon they were putting names
in the frame that weren't involved in
the discussions in doha before the
taliban takeover
well it is an interesting transition for
a movement which has been a fighting
force for the last two decades to now
change itself all of a sudden to a
governing body and this is what you're
seeing in doha now america
you see this statesman from a taliban
fighter the evolution of these group
into a government where at least they're
trying to be this is
hugely significant because it is the
first meeting where the taliban interim
government is interacting with the rest
of the world not on their soil they have
moved to doha
after long weeks of discussions the
earlier we were talking to taliban
leaders who were telling us that there
can be no negotiations until the united
states fulfills its obligations uh that
it had in writing committed with the
taliban in doha but then they moved from
that and they wanted to go to doha there
was a lot of shuttle diplomacy from the
qatari special envoy going to new york
going to kabul going to taha meeting
people and then in the lead up to this
meeting you saw the un representative
designated by the taliban meeting not
just ambassadors uh from the region but
international players as well and
taliban saying that they are going to be
talking to european union leaders as
well so there is a lot that is at stake
here for the taliban as you heard
earlier that they are there because they
want to help the afghan people they just
don't have the money as you've been
hearing the reports that uh as the
former government went it took all the
money with them and billions and
billions of dollars are now
frozen for the afghan international at
the afghan central bank as well so of
course there is a myriad of problems
that afghanistan faces economics being
the first one because winter is
approaching millions of people are
desperately in need of aid and we've
been seeing visits from the united
nations bodies the world health
organizations doctors without borders
everybody underlining the fact that the
international community
has probably weeks not months to act and
they have they cannot use the aid and
the afghan money that they're frozen as
a bargaining chip to put taliban into
the shape that they want them to be
osama bin javed there in kabul thanks
osama talk to you later